- The cost of safely disposing
of the toxic chemicals
is approximately five times
what the company paid to purchase it.
And maybe we have no error.
So this first part reads
a little bit weird,
but I think it's right.
Let's see.
The cost of safely disposing
of the toxic chemicals.
Yeah, there's a lot of of's
there, but I think that's right.
I mean, we could have said
the cost of disposing of,
and this safely is just an adverb
describing how we're disposing.
We're safely disposing.
So this seems reasonable.
The cost of safely disposing
of the toxic chemicals.
It's a little bit a lot of wordy.
It's got the of's there,
but it doesn't seem wrong.
The cost of safely disposing of
the toxic chemicals is approximately.
So we're talking about the cost.
So it's a singular subject,
and so it makes sense that we
would use is right over here.
We'd use the singular verb.
The cost is approximately five times
what the company paid to purchase it.
Now this it is a little bit fishy.
What is this it referring to?
Is this it referring to the cost?
Is it referring to the cost?
No.
The it, I think, based on
the meaning of the sentence,
they're referring to the chemicals.
The company paid to
purchase the chemicals.
So this right over here
should be the chemicals.
The chemicals, or if they
want to use a pronoun,
this is a plural noun right
over here, the chemicals,
you would use to purchase them.
You would use to purchase them.
You wouldn't use it right over here.
What did they purchase?
They purchased the toxic chemicals.
So it's plural.
So you would either say
to purchase the chemicals
or to purchase them.
So let's just read it with them.
The cost of safely disposing
of the toxic chemicals
is approximately five
times what the company paid
to purchase them.
Yeah, that makes a little bit more sense,
or if you want to be very clear,
you could just write the chemicals there.
The cost of safely disposing
of the toxic chemicals
is approximately five
times what the company paid
to purchase the chemicals.
Yeah, that makes it, at least in my mind,
that's how I would have written
it, making it very clear.